Hello everybody welcome back to the
farming simar 25 tips and tricks video
today we're continuing our Series where
we talk about all the crops and farming
sim25 by focusing on wheat barley and
oats now we're combining all three of
these grain crops into a single video
because they all share something in
common that is that we can put down a
straw windro after harvest and then
collect that straw windro in one of
couple various ways and use that straw
in again multiple ways now we've learned
through our animal videos that many of
the various animals will accept straw as
beding and as result will produce manure
we also know by our TMR video that we'll
be able to use straw to make total mixed
rations for our cows and water buffalo
or you can just choose to collect the
straw and sell it whichever thing fits
your
fancy now this video is also going to
focus on well what can you do with your
grain after you harvest it because we
have a couple different Productions that
we can run our grain through
we can run our wheat barley or oats
through the Grain Mill and produce flour
and once we produce that flour we can
take it to a secondary production in the
bakery and produce bread or cakes with
that flour our oats can go over here to
the cereal factory in combination with a
few other products in order to make
cereal as a finished good in addition we
really haven't talked about storing
crops in any of our videos up to this
point and for the most part that is
because up till this point we haven't
been able to technically store any of
those crops that we have done videos on
that is about to change because we can
store Wheat barley and oats in any
ingame Silo so I've got placed here a
few different samples of the silos that
are available in game we have kind of an
old school Brick and concrete
variety we have more of an Americanized
concrete Silo here a more modern steel
Silo and then we have a singular grain
bin and we're going to be doing a
separate video talking about silos
specifically and demonstrating how we
can make use of these grain bin silos
with the use of
augers now once you have harvested your
crop you're going to be able to collect
the straw and in order to collect the
straw you can either use a Bor which we
have already demonstrated in our hay and
grass video or you can make use of a
forge wagon which is how we're going to
be collecting the straw
today in addition to harvesting our
wheat barley and oats a single time
we're going to be coming through a
second time and harvesting the same
field but this time we're going to use
the macdon swather from the macdon pack
because I can tell you in in my testing
already we see a
24.9% basically 25% bonus to our output
by swapping our crop with the Macon and
then picking that swath up with our
pickup header Again part of the macdon
pack with our Harvester and then we're
also seeing a bonus with respect to our
straw that we collected off those fields
as
well now we caveat this that the macdown
pack is an upgrade it is an add-on bonus
at this point a paid DLC I received the
macdown pack as a pre-order bonus as did
many that pre-ordered the game but at
this point now that the game is out
there is going to be a paid DLC that is
the macdown pack if you are interested
that I do have a link to that down in
the description below it is using my
affiliate code so it wouldn't be much
obliged if you would make use of that
code if you go ahead and pick up that
macdown pack now that code is going to
be able to be used for PC players only
if you are a console player then by all
means pick up the macdown pack via your
store of your console of
choice now let's take a look at some
infog graphics now these infog Graphics
come from the Farming Simulator Academy
which is the tutorial site over at the
Giants website and got information here
about oats and I've run various tests
already on oat and
barley it says seeds per hectar 500 now
on field 41 which we are using because
it is very near one hectar in size I
only use 329 L worth the seed here in
Farm Sim 25 so it does appear that our
seed usage is down from what is listed
here on this infographic from FS2
to what is accurate is the planting
season of March and April the growing
duration of 4 months and the Harvest
duration of July and August those things
are accurately
reflected the yield per hectar 5700 l i
saw a yield that was
93% bonus to this my field was prepared
at plus 95% I saw a 93% in increase I
actually was able to harvest
11,043 L worth of Oats using the
traditional cloth grain Harvester and
the
macdon
header more on that here in a moment as
far as straw I was able to collect
71,2 L worth of straw after I harvested
with the traditional cloth
Harvester by using the swapping method
using the macdon and then following it
up with the pickup header using the
cloth I was able to harvest
13,798 L worth of Oats that would be a
24.9% increase over the CL Harvester the
traditional way of harvesting or a
242 increase over the yield per hectar
listed here in this
infographic in addition I was able to
harvest our straw after using the back
dawn after using the pickup header with
the Closs
87,3 191 l so an increase of
approximately 1,600 L of
straw now with respect to our
barley barley again lists needing 500 L
of seed per hectar I used
257 basically half of that seed usage so
again this infographic seems to be a
little bit off for Farm Sim 25 what is
accurate is the planting season of
September in October and the Harvest
duration of June through July so it has
a growing duration of 9 months basically
over winter and
spring yield per hectar was 9600 L well
when I ran my Closs Harvester with the
macdon header I saw 18,000
595 L of harvest that was again a
93% increase over what is listed here on
this infographic and my field was listed
as having a plus 95%
bonus after collecting the grain I went
around and collected the straw and I
basically saw the same output that I got
with oats at 71,0 8
L then comes swafing with the macdon
after I SWA with the macdon I used a
pickup header from the macdon pack with
the CL Harvester and I received
23,2 128 L worth of barley that again
was a 29 or
24.9% increase from what we had with the
traditional Harvester or a
242 increase from what is listed here on
this
infographic I then collected a straw and
I didn't see quite the increase of straw
that I had with oats I only saw
85587 l so a little bit of a reduction
there I'm going to call that margin of
error because well maybe there was a
couple things that I did wrong on that
field and that might be a result why the
straw was a little bit
lower now with respect to our wheat and
I haven't done this test so we're going
to be doing this test
together says our seeds per hectar will
be 500 later so be interesting to see do
I do about 250 or do I do a little bit
more than that we are planning our wheat
in September and October and then we're
going to be able to harvest the
following year in July or August so a
10mon growing duration and we're going
to have an average yield of
8,900 L per hectar so keep remembering
that number because we will be coming
back to that in a little bit
now let's run
through the vehicle shop and where we're
going to get all this stuff I apologize
I shouldn't have been standing by the
Grain Mill that was a little annoying
for me I'm sure that was annoying for
everyone else let's take a look at our
vehicle
shop so with respect to our
Harvesters we're going to come to
combine harvesting and we're going to be
able to basically use any of these
Harvesters to harvest our grain now I
have the Gold Edition because I also
happen to have pre-ordered from the
Giants eShop and also have a collector's
edition so that is why this appears if
anyone has any questions for this video
we're using the
lexion
6900 standard base
configuration in combination with your
combine harvester you're going to need a
grain header you can use any of these
grain headers for this particular video
I'm going to be making use of the macdon
flex Draper from the macdon pack just to
see if there would be any sort of
differences between the flex Draper and
any of these other headers now of course
you can use literally any header with
any Harvester but you should note that
these bigger headers well your pipe may
not clear the header and if that's the
case you're going to run into a little
bit of difficulty in offloading your
Harvester so what I would suggest is
coming here to a harvester figuring out
which Harvester you want to use coming
down here to combinations and it will
tell you the appropriate combinations of
headers that will work best with the
particular Harvester that you have
selected so we can see here the listing
of headers for this particular size
Closs Harvester and if I come up here
and I select a smaller gloss Harvester
but you're going to see it is going to
suggest a different set of headers same
can be said for the larger CLA Harvester
we're going to again we're going to get
a different set of header
choices with respect to collecting our
straw well you're going to be able to
use a 4ed wagon and in this particular
video we're going to be using the fent
tigro 75
vrd or you can come through with a
square Bor or r B to bail that
straw as far as seeding goes we're going
to seed our wheat barley and oats with a
traditional Cedar and for this video I'm
going to be using lykin sultar 12 so
back here in our shop if we scroll up to
seeding we're going to find a category
of Cedars and we can use any of these
seeders to put our wheat barley or oats
in the ground for this video we're using
the sultar 12 and we can use our seed in
the form of a ballet pallet big bag a
big bag or a pallet of little bags the
two big bags are going to cost
$1,260 and provide you with 1,000 lers
worth of seed whereas the Pioneer pallet
of bags is going to give you 50 extra
lers worth of seed for the same cost as
the rest you can also find your seed
down here under objects
in big bag
categories big bag pallet category and
pallets with respect to our field prep I
have already gone ahead and prepared
this field it is been plowed or does it
need plowing it has had lime applied to
it it has actually already been
fertilized to 100% and it has already
been cul ated so it is right and ready
for our seating and that is exactly what
we are about to
do I'm going to load this Cedar up with
1,000 L worth the seed just to make it a
bit easier on the math
and a lot of seater we're just going to
pull up here alongside our big bag
pallet and we're going to hit R to load
our
seed it looks like it has decided to
load our pallet bags as opposed to
whatever doesn't matter so we'll start
with 1,50 L now the game defaults us to
wheat which is exactly what we want to
put in the ground but if we did want to
change it just to Barley or oats we
would hit Y until the respective crop
does come up just going to toggle back
over
to
wheat we're going to address the field
as we have seen in other videos if you
have seen
those we going to lower our Cedar
[Music]
down turn it on with B
and Off to the Races we
go so I'm going to keep track of how
much seed we've put to the ground and I
will report back once we
have
finished so we've down to 752 L wor of
seed and that means that basically we
have used 298 L of seed because so again
we started at
1,50 because we grabbed the wrong pallet
or the seed so any rate we're kind of
we're kind of in the middle there right
where barley used less seed at 257 L oat
used more seed at 329 L and wheat is
kind of there in the middle at 298 but
still it is lower than the infographics
500 L per hectar as reported from the
academy me which was built around
fs22 now I am going to go ahead and weed
this field with
herbicide because if we come over here
and check the field stats
out it says we are at plus
92% and it we have weeds
growing so like I said I'm going to go
ahead and spray this and and
uh see if we can get her up to
95% it's just like magic we've moved
into October we have our first growth of
our wheat on the field and I think let's
go ahead and talk about our crop
calendar for these various crops again
wheat as we mentioned with the
infographic you're going to be able to
plant it in September and October you're
going to have to wait 10 months the
entire of Winter the entirety of spring
all the way up to July before you can
start to harvest that wheat and you have
until the end of August to get all the
wheat off the ground otherwise it's
going to wilt with respect to Barley
well again we can plant that in
September and October although Barley's
going to be available one month sooner
and the fact we only have to wait nine
months until June and July in order to
get our barley off the field now the the
Speedy Gonzales of all of these crops is
oat oat you have to plant in March or
April and then well just a few short
months afterwards in July or August of
the same year you're going to be able to
get those oats off the ground so if you
don't like waiting well then oats might
be the crop for
you let's go ahead and move forward
into September and we'll check on our
crop soly me I was already in September
so how can I fast forward to September
it's now November and you can see we
still have our first grow State
basically of our
wheat let's go ahead and move on into
spring so I'll see you all back around
the March time
frame winter is over spring is here and
as such are we wheat has now moved into
the second growth state so don't be
surprised if your wheat doesn't grow at
all from November or September up till
March that's pretty normal it's going to
be in winter it's going to be dormant
and now that this weather is starting to
warm up sun's out a little bit more
longer while your wheat is going to
start to grow like weeds thankfully
there aren't any weeds in this
field May is here and our crop is coming
along quite nicely with respect to our
wheat so just another two months and
we'll be ready to
harvest okay so July is here our wheat
is ready to harvest and it is at this
stage where I am going to save the game
because I want to be able to after we
Harvest our wheat I'm going to bring you
back we're going to tabulate our our
results of our wheat Harvest and our
straw collection after that wheat
Harvest then I'm going to load this save
game back up exactly to this
point and then we are going to run the
same Harvest this time using the
macdon and then we will tabulate our
results and close everything out now as
I've said I've already run the results
for barley and I've already run the
results for oats we've already kind of
gone over those results but we will go
over those results again after we
tabulate our wheat results and I've done
this exact method with the other two
crops so we're just going to repeat this
exact method we need to switch over to
straw
actually let's not switch over to straw
I want to I want to demonstrate
something so this is a little bit of a
variance from what I did with our barley
and our
oats but I do want to demonstrate
something so our straw will be slightly
reduced with respect to our wheat
Harvest because we are changing up our
methodology just a little bit and that
is that I wanted to
demonstrate that if we come here and we
check
our soil
composition we can see that this area
here which we have just scattered straw
to the wind is listed as mulched this
area over here which we did not get any
straw
on is not
mulched as we now lay down
a straw
SWA okay we are now going to be able to
collect our
straw we're going to see that we are not
leaving this field in a
mulched
state you see that we are
basically removing the mulch State
because this field had a mulched state
from theoretically the previous year's
Harvest so with your wheat barley and
oats you have a
choice do you get straw in a wi row such
that you can collect it and use it for
bedding use it for TMR or or just sell
it for additional
money or do you scatter that straw to
the wind as we demonstrated by turning
off the straw
SWA and if you do that then you will not
be able to collect the straw instead you
will basically be given a mulch State on
your field so a 22% bonus
to the next crop that you put into this
field what you should so do is up to
you I personally think that I would
rather collect the straw because I have
other uses for the straw and a 2 and
half% yield bonus really isn't that
attractive to me versus collecting the
money from selling the straw and as I'm
sure we will find out when it comes to
using the
macdon if I can get 25% more
crop 2 and 1 12% better
yield maybe it offsets by a lot maybe it
doesn't matter because I also get a
whole lot more strong and therefore I
can collect more money or make more TMR
or get and use more manure depending on
if we are needing to use it or
not so let me go ahead and finish this
and I'll report
back so our Harvest is over and we have
collected
17,23 L for the wheat if you remember
from our infographic it said that we
would have
8900 lers worth of wheat so that means
that we we have a yield of
93% over what the infographic said which
is pretty darn close to our 95% yield
bonus of
17,23
L now let's run through our Harvest
totals for our barley our barley we had
18,
595 lers worth of barley after
Harvest so a little bit more barley than
we had wheat and we had
11, 43 L worth of
Oats a decent amount less than our wheat
and barley but if we look at our prices
screen here I think we're going to
see that our barley well it's going to
have an average high of
$1,137 on easy at an average low of
763 with respect to our oats though an
average high of
1883 with an average low of
1314 so our oats are more valuable than
our
barley and then our wheat is going to be
1,90 when average low of
832 so a little bit more
than our barley but a fair bit less than
our
oats kind of holds to the overall yields
doesn't
it now let's go and collect our straw
now remember we scatter to the
wind the straw on the other end of the
field when it comes time to doing our
swathing testing with the macdon swather
we will
also not collect the straw that is on
the North part of the
field uh simply
to be the same as this run and that
should basically then normalize our
straw totals between the two
tests but again we're going to expect
less
straw than we had with our are barley
and oat numbers because I didn't scatter
this end of the field in those tests but
more or less we're comparing our
standard Harvest and our macdown
swapping for the same crop as opposed to
our straw output between the different
crops so with respect to our straw and
remember our numbers are going to be
lower because we didn't SWA or leave a
wind row to the other side of the field
we collected
65,7 25 L with the straw with our
traditional
Harvest now we're going to load up the
save game and we're going to make use of
the macdon in order to swath the crop
we're going to make use of the pickup
header to then pick up that swath and
separate the grain from the straw and
then we will go back and use the forage
wagon to collect the straw and then
we'll compare the numbers we just got
with those
numbers okay so here we are loaded up
with the macdon with the save game right
where we were before and let's go ah and
talk about the macdown pack before we
get too far into it so under mods and
DLCs we have the macdown Pack we the
m1240 this is going to be the swather
this is going to be the vehicle that
drives
everything and we have the choice of
different engines here we have 173
horsepower or 262 horsepower we can
change the tire
types and that is pretty much
it then we have the
macdon swathing
header so we can get this with transport
wheels or
not and the way this can work is we can
transport this like we would transport a
rain header and we'd actually put the
macdon in Reverse drive to do that it's
a pretty neat setup we then have the
mowing head so this is what we're going
to use to mow our grass then we have the
pickup head which is going to be used on
our standard Harvester to pick up the
swap that we're putting down and then we
have the fd1 40 Flex straper this is
actually the header that we're using on
our class Harvester so this is going to
be a traditional grain header 12.5 m
versus the swather which is 12.2 M so
they're very similar in working
with the swather will be able to swath
wheat barley oat canola and soybeans so
those are the crops that we are going to
do this test with with respect to
comparing standard Harvest to swapping
Harvest and the way this works we're
just going to turn our header on we're
going to drop it down and we are going
to basically dive into the
field we're going to use one Headland
we're going to go ahead and set that up
so we can keep our nice line straight
and the way this works is it cuts the
crop and gently lays it on the header or
belts that move it toward the middle and
then
the swather just
runs over top of that and straddles it
for the most
part and we're going to go ahead
and make a cut on either either side of
the field and then I just want to
demonstrate using the CL Harvester and
the pickup header this is exactly how I
did it with the other two
props is I did a cut off across the top
of the field I did two cuts along the
long
sides and then I harvested the swath
with the standard
Harvester such that I wasn't driving
over the crop too much when I was
harvesting the rest of the
field then I also went ahead and canted
that straw so again I wasn't driving
over any of that as I was harvesting the
field so let me finish this cut and I'll
come back with our CLA Harvester and
demonstrate the pickup
header so if we take a quick look at
our wheat swath we can see that we can
actually see the wheat heads in this
texture so the grain is still here all
we've done is cut it and lay it down
nice and gently on the
field now we can come through with our
standard rain Harvester with this custom
pickup
header and you'll see what this header
does is it gently picks the crop up off
the
field and and then runs it through the
Harvester and since it is being
gentle with the crop then we are in
essence getting more yield because we
are losing less of the
crop just like we did with our weed
Harvest we scattered the Top Cut Across
the
field and we're going to get that as
a mulching bonus and now we are leaving
straw
behind and let's compare the straw
windro the heads are gone
now we don't actually see the Grain on
there anymore so that is our straw
windro versus our wheat swath
all right let me go ahead and finish
this out and I'll be back and we'll
close this video
out all right so let's crunch some
numbers here we finished our weed
Harvest I have
21, 533 l in this trailer and again this
wheat was harvested with the macdon then
we used the pickup header with our
traditional Harvester to extract the
grain from the straw then we used our
Forge wagon to pick the straw up so
21532 that is a
24.9% Bas 25% increase for all intense
purposes above and beyond the
traditional Harvest with the traditional
Macon grain header and the CL Harvester
which again netted us
17,23 2 L off of a field that had a plus
95% bonus We have basically a plus 93%
bonus off of the Baseline Harvest crop
value of 8900 L per the Giants Academy
infographic now as far as our straw
goes I
collected two full loads from our fent
our fent holds 40,500 l so that would be
81,000 L with the straw from the field
that again used the macdon the pickup
header with the Harvester and then our
Forge wagon that is a 24% increase from
the straw that we had just off the clth
Harvester itself at
L if we go back now to to our
barley remember I said our barley with
the traditional Harvester we had
lers with our swather using the macdon
sorry and then the pickup header we
increased by 25% to 23,2 28 L our straw
with the coloss Harvester 71,0 in8 L our
straw after swapping with the macdon 85
L oats our standard Harvest with our CLA
Harvester 11,043
L we had
13,798 L with the macdon then the pickup
header and the Closs Harvester a
24.9%
bonus with respect to our straw we had
21,26 L wor the straw
sorry
71,2 L worth the straw with the CL
Harvester and
87,3 191 L worth of straw after using
the macdon a
23%
bonus so the straw bonus is is around
the same bonus as our Harvest although
it wasn't as
consistent and I would attribute it not
being as consistent to that the header
we used on
both the
macdon and the traditional CLA Harvester
was just a little bit too
narrow to get all of the field without
having a little bit left over so there
was this little REM Remer left over here
in this general
area and what I have found is the macdon
pickup header that picks up straw
swath does not necessarily like to pick
up small wind RS of
swath so we will leave a little bit here
that couldn't be picked up if I bring
that header back over over here it
likely isn't going to be able to pick
up these little bits here and
there of straw
swath and as a result of not being a
pick up the straw swath it couldn't pick
up the straw in addition there was a
couple areas
where well we had straw that came out
late and it's over here on the other
side of the field we couldn't pick it up
yada yada yada so that's why I'm
attributing a little bit more variance
with our straw collection over our grain
collection but it's pretty clear that
the macdon while in a previous video we
saw gave no bonus to grass is giving us
a bonus for wheat barley and oats we're
going to continue to do this test when
we get to our canola video and our
soybean video see if we continue to see
that 25%
bonus now what are we going to do with
this
graen we talked about storing it and we
talked about being able to use it in
production I wanted to demonstrate
storing
it now we know we can store the straw
from our hay and grass video we can
store that in the hay loft which is
going to be found here under
silos Hay Loft right this we can store
our straw in if we wanted to store it
loose or of course we could bail it and
if we bailed it then we could put it in
our bail storage
building if we restore our grain well we
could just come up here
to any one of these silos
and dump our
grain and then we'll be able to also
bring our grain out of it if we have one
of these single
bins I can't the camera won't let me get
to that if we have one of the singular
Bend
silos well we're going to have to
use an augur in order to pull grain out
of that I'm going to have a separate
video on how to do all of that basically
we're going to come down here and we're
going to find our
augers under
miscellaneous belt
systems the Meridian will be used to
take grain out of The Silo meanwhile the
convey all will use to put grain
Into The Silo but again we're going to
have a completely separate video on that
a little bit later
if we look here at our
production our Grain Mill well we can
bring barley oat and wheat to our Grain
Mill five units of wheat is going to
make four units of
flour 30 units of barley is going to
make 22 units of
flour and 15 units of oat is going to
make 15 units of flour so this is a one:
one meanwhile with with our wheat and
our barley we're putting in more grain
then we're getting flour
out with respect to our Cereal Factory
well we're going to be able to
bring oats to our Cereal Factory and we
can make chocolate cereal 36 units of
corn 36 units of oat 10 units of
chocolate 10 units of Honey to 20 units
of
cereal or we can make raisin
cereal 40 units of corn 40 units with
the oats 10 units of raisins 10 units of
Honey 20 units of cereal the other two
cereals are going to be exclusively for
rice and therefore are not going to be
able to make use of our
oats our Bakery is going to be a down
process with respect to our flour that
we make and we can make bread with our
flour 90 units of bread for 45 unit
9 units of flour 45 units of bread
basically two to one two units of flour
is going to make one unit of bread or we
could use cakes and that is going to
require a lot more ingredients but 8
units of flour 8 units of sugar 8 units
of milk eight units of eggs butter and
strawberries are all going to make 21
units worth of
cake what you should decide to do with
respect to your grain is basically up to
you now we can also use our wheat and
barley with respect to our pigs so right
there it's also going to be eligible for
pig
food so guys I hope that has giving you
a good idea as to what your wheat barley
and oat is good for also how to harvest
how to seed and how to care for your
wheat barley and oats or
overall let me know down in the comments
below what do you think of our tips and
tricks series are you looking forward to
the next video I've got one hopefully
scheduled every day for the remainder of
this month if you're watching it fairly
soon after the video is dropped
otherwise this is basically a historical
reference for anyone coming into the
game that is not quite sure how to do
any one of these specific crops
until next time happy
farming for